all have wanted to be here
because our united kingdom is a beacon
of openness
and generosity
and all in turn have contributed
magnificently to the amazing story of
the uk
today
that proud history of safe and legal
migration
is ultimately responsible for many of
those working in our hospitals and on
the front line of our response to the
pandemic
for more than 60 percent of the england
football team at the final of euro 2020
for many of our country's leading
figures in the worlds of business art
and culture
and i'm pleased to say for ever-growing
numbers of people serving in public life
including colleagues of mine
like nadim zahawi who escaped with his
family from saddam hussein's iraq
dominic raag whose jewish father came to
britain from czechoslovakia to escape
nazi germany and pretty patel whose
family fled persecution in uganda
so i'm proud that this government has
continued the great british tradition of
providing sanctuary to those in need
in fact doing more to resettle
vulnerable people in the uk
through safe and legal routes than any
other government in recent history since
2015 we've offered a place to over 185
000 men women and children seeking
refuge more than the entire population
of sunderland
and more than any other similar
resettlement schemes in europe this
includes almost a hundred thousand
british nationals overseas threatened by
draconian security laws in hong kong
twenty thousand through our syrian
scheme
thirteen thousand from afghanistan uh
and whom we owe debts of honor and
around 50 000 ukrainians
and we're not only supporting british
nationals and those settled in the uk to
bring potentially hundreds of thousands
uh to their extent of their extended
family from ukraine
were also welcoming unlimited numbers of
refugees from that conflict as the
british people open their homes
in one of the biggest movements of
refugees to this country that we've ever
known
and
as we work with local authorities
and the devolved administrations to
welcome those coming from ukraine into
our communities
we will also find accommodation across
our whole uk for all those who have come
here previously but who are currently in
hotels
because it makes absolutely no sense for
the taxpayer to foot those bills running
to almost 5 million pounds a day
with the sum total of those we
accommodate being concentrated in just a
third of local authorities
it is controlled immigration
through safe and legal routes
which enables us to make generous offers
of sanctuary
while managing the inevitable pressures
on our public services
such that we can give all those who come
here the support they need to rebuild
their lives to integrate and to thrive
but the quid pro quo for this generosity
is that we cannot sustain a parallel
illegal system our compassion
may be infinite but our capacity to help
people is not
we can't ask the british taxpayer to
write a blank check to cover the costs
of anyone who might want to come and
live here
uncontrolled immigration creates
unmanageable demands on our nhs and on
our welfare state it overstretches our
local schools our housing and public
transport and creates unsustainable
pressure to build on precious green
spaces
nor is it fair on those who are seeking
to come here legally
if others can bypass the system
it's a striking fact that around 7 out
of 10 of those arriving in small boats
last year were men under 40 paying
people smugglers to q-jump
and taking up our capacity to help
genuine women and child refugees
this is particularly perverse as those
attempting crossings are not directly
fleeing imminent peril
as is the intended purpose of the asylum
system they've passed through manifestly
safe countries
including many in europe where they
could and should have claimed asylum
it is this rank unfairness of a system
that can be exploited by gangs which
risks eroding public support for the
whole concept of asylum
the british people voted several times
to control our borders not to close them
but to control them
so justice brexit allowed us to take
back control of legal immigration
by replacing free movement with our
points-based system
we're also taking back control of
illegal immigration with a long-term
plan for asylum in this country
it is a plan that will ensure the uk has
a world-leading asylum offer providing
generous protection to those directly
fleeing the worst of humanity
by settling thousands of people every
year
through safe and legal routes and i
emphasize this so whether you're fleeing
putin or assad our aim is that you
should not need to turn to the people
smugglers or any other kind of illegal
option
but to deliver that we must first ensure
that the only route to asylum to in the
uk is a safe and legal one and that
those who try to jump the queue or abuse
our system
will find no automatic path to
settlement in our country
but rather be swiftly and humanely
removed to a safe
third country or their country of origin
and
the most tragic
of all forms
of illegal migration
which we must end with this approach
is the barbaric trade in human misery
conducted by the people smugglers in the
channel
before christmas 27 people drowned and
in the weeks ahead there could be many
more losing their lives at sea and whose
bodies may never be recovered
around 600 came across the channel
yesterday
in just a few weeks this could again
reach a thousand
a day
i accept that these people whether
they're six hundred or a thousand are in
search of a better life
the opportunities that the united
kingdom provides
and the hope of a fresh start
but it is these hopes
those dreams that have been exploited
these vile people smugglers are abusing
the vulnerable
and turning the channel into a watery
graveyard with men women and children
drowning in unsee-worthy boats and
suffocating in refrigerated lorries
and
even if they do make it here
we know only too well some of the
horrendous stories of exploitation over
the years from the nail bars of east
london to the cockle beds of morecambe
bay
as illegal migration makes people more
vulnerable to the brutal abuse of
ruthless gangs so
we must halt this appalling trade
and defeat
the people smugglers
that's why we're passing the nationality
and borders bill which allows us for the
first time to distinguish between people
coming here legally and illegally
and for this distinction to affect how
your asylum claim progresses and your
status in the uk if that claim is
successful
it will enable us to issue visa
penalties against those countries that
refuse to accept returns of foreign
criminals and failed asylum seekers
it will clean up the abuse of our legal
system introducing a one-stop shop that
will end the cycle of last-minute and
vexatious claims and appeals that so
often thwart and delay removals
and it will end the absurd practice of
asylum seeking adults claiming to be
children to strengthen their claims and
access better services
crucially
it will also allow us to prosecute those
who arrive illegally with life sentences
for anyone piloting the boats
and to identify
intercept
and investigate these boats from today
the royal navy will take take over
operational command from border force in
the channel taking primacy for our
operational response at sea in line with
many of our international partners with
the aim that no boat makes it to the uk
undetected
this will be supported by 50 million
pounds of new funding for new boats
aerial surveillance and military
personnel
in addition to the existing task force
of patrol vessels wildcat helicopters
search and rescue aircraft drones and
remotely piloted aircraft
this will send a clear message
to those piloting the boats
if you risk other people's lives in the
channel
you risk
spending
your own life
in prison
people who do make it to the uk
will be taken not to hotels at vast
public expense
rather they will be housed in
accommodation centers like those in
greece with the first of these to open
shortly
at the same time
we are expanding our immigration
detention facilities to assist with the
removal of those with no right to remain
in the uk
we're investing over half a billion
pounds in those efforts and this is on
top of overhauling our arrivals
infrastructure here in kent with new
processing facilities now operation
operational at western jet foil and at
manston
but we will need to go further in
breaking the business model
of these gangs
so from today
our new migration and economic
development partnership will mean that
anyone entering the uk illegally
as well as those who have arrived
illegally since january the first
may now
be relocated to rwanda
this innovative approach driven by our
shared humanitarian impulse and made
possible by brexit freedoms
will provide
safe and legal routes
for asylum
while disrupting the business model of
the gangs
because it means that economic migrants
taking advantage of the asylum system
will not get to stay in the uk
while those in genuine need
will be properly protected including
with access to legal services on arrival
in rwanda and given the opportunity to
build a new life in that dynamic country
supported by the funding we are
providing
the deal we've done
is uncapped and rwanda will have the
capacity to resettle tens of thousands
of people
in the years ahead and let's be clear
rwanda is one of the safest countries in
the world
globally recognized for its record on
welcoming and integrating migrants
later this year it will welcome leaders
from across the commonwealth and before
the pandemic in 2018 the imf said rwanda
was the world's fourth fastest growing
economy
we're confident that our new migration
partnership is fully compliant with our
international legal obligations
but nevertheless we expect
this will be challenged in the courts
and if this country is seen as a soft
touch for illegal migration by some of
our partners it is precisely because we
have such a formidable army of
politically motivated lawyers who for
years have made it their business to
thwart removals and frustrate the
government
so
i know that this system will not take
effect overnight
but i promise that we will do whatever
it takes to deliver this new approach
initially within the limits of the
existing legal and constitutional
frameworks
but also prepared to explore any and all
further legal reforms which may be
necessary
because this problem has bedeviled our
country for too long
and caused
far too much human suffering and tragedy
and this is the government that refuses
to duck the difficult decisions this is
the government that makes the big calls
and i profoundly believe there is simply
no other option
and i say to those who would criticize
our plan today well we have a plan what
is your alternative now
i know
there are some who believe we should
just turn these boats back at sea
but after much study and consultation
including uh with border force the
police national crime agency and
military maritime experts to whom by the
way i paid tribute for all the
incredible work that they do dealing
with this problem as things stand
it's clear
that there are extremely limited
circumstances when you can safely do
this in the english channel and it
doesn't help that this approach i don't
think would be supported by our french
partners and i've got to say to you that
relying solely on this course of action
is simply not practical in in my view
and i know of course that there are
others who should say who would say we
should just negotiate a deal with france
and the eu and we've made repeated and
generous offers
to our french friends and we will
continue to press them and the eu for
the comprehensive returns agreement that
would solve this problem
we remain grateful to the gendarmes on
the beach for the joint intelligence
work and the cooperation that has
stopped thousands of votes
we would like to deepen that work and we
continue to believe that a deal with
france and the eu is in the national
interests of all our countries
but we must have our own framework
for full sovereignty over our borders
and we must find a way to stop these
boats now
not lose thousands more lives while
waiting for a deal that just doesn't
exist
and i know that there will be a vocal
minority who will think that these
measures are draconian and lacking in
compassion and i simply don't agree
there is no humanity or compassion
in allowing desperate and innocent
people to have their dreams of a better
life exploited by ruthless gangs as
they're taken to their deaths in
unseaworthy boats and there's no
humanity or compassion
in endlessly condemning the people
smugglers
but then time and again ducking the big
calls needed to break the business model
of the gangs and stop these boats from
coming
and there's no humanity or compassion
in calling for unlimited
safe and legal routes offering the false
hope of asylum in the uk to anyone who
wants it because
that
is just unsustainable
there are currently 80 million displaced
people in the world many in failed
states where governments can't meet
their aspirations
in an era of mobile connectivity they
are a call or a text away from
potentially being swept up in the tide
of people smuggling
the answer cannot be for the uk to
become the haven for all of them that's
a call for open borders by the back door
a political argument masquerading as a
humanitarian policy those in favor of
this approach should be honest about it
and argue for it openly
we reject it as the british people have
consistently rejected it at the ballot
box in favor of controlled immigration
we simply cannot have a policy of saying
anyone who wants to live here can do so
we've got to be able to control who
comes into this country and the terms on
which they remain and we must do this
in the spirit of our history
of providing refuge
and
in that way we can more than play our
part in offering sanctuary to thousands
fleeing persecution but then of course
other countries
must play their part too and that's what
i think is most exciting
about the partnership we've agreed with
rwanda today
because we believe it will become a new
international standard
in addressing the challenges of global
migration and people smuggling
so i'm grateful for rwanda's leadership
and partnership and we stand ready to
work with other nations on similar
agreements as well as wider reforms to
the international asylum framework
as i say we will continue to work with
our french friends to tackle the gangs
we will continue to lead cooperation
with crime and intelligence partners
across europe we'll continue to seek a
returns agreement
with the eu or with france
but in the meantime
and for the foreseeable future
we need this new approach
the people smugglers are undermining
confidence in our borders
they are betraying all those who do the
right thing who try to come here legally
through forms of migration or the safe
and legal routes provided for refuge
they're undermining the natural
compassion and goodwill that people have
towards refugees in this country and
they are endangering human life day
after day
and the way ahead will be hard and
though we can expect many challenges and
many obstacles to be thrown up against
this plan i believe this plan is the
right way forward because the people
smugglers must be stopped
in order to save countless lives
and because tackling illegal migration
is precisely the way to sustain a safe
legal
and generous offer of sanctuary to those
in need
and that is in the very best traditions
of this country and the values we stand
for in the world
thank you all very much indeed
i'm now going to go to
the media for
uh for some questions i'm going to go
first to nick early of the bbc
thanks prime minister is the plan to
send asylum seekers to rwanda a genuine
answer is it a workable solution or is
it an attempt to look tough on an issue
which the government's failed to address
in the last few years and if i can ask
about the fine you received earlier this
week do you still think you have the
moral authority to govern what would you
say to the people
watching at home who think that
you have been guilty of hypocrisy for
not following the rules you told them
they must follow and what would you say
to the mps who think you lied to them
well thanks very much nick and look on
your second point i i said quite a lot
about this on
i think it was uh
tuesday uh i'll be saying more when i
update parliament as you can imagine uh
next week i think you you probably have
to wait until uh then for me to say uh
say more on on on that but on uh
you know whether this is a a solution
that uh is you know a magic bullet as it
were that can deal with the problem of
illegal migration across the the channel
i want to be absolutely clear with
everybody uh i think that this is
necessary but it is of course not
sufficient uh there are many other
things that we need
to get right we need to make sure that
our legal
framework is capable of of dealing with
the problem as well as the practical
steps that we can take but none of the
reforms to our uh to our laws will
really be any good without the the basic
ability to get in the heads of the of
the people smugglers and make them
understand that the uh the deal they're
offering uh their poor
uh
vulnerable
clients is not one that stacks up and
it's to get into the heads of the of the
people who are coming uh across the
channel risking their lives in this way
that they're much much better off going
for the safe and legal routes that we
have rather than paying
to jump the queue and to risk their
lives because
if they if they go that way if they come
across the channel illegally in these in
these vessels then
they uh risk
as i've as i've explained uh ending up
not in the uk uh but in rwanda and
that is something that i believe will
over time prove a very considerable
deterrent but there are several things
that you've got to get right in addition
uh to that policy not least uh the legal
framework because i've got no doubt at
all uh that this will be challenged and
uh there will be a long way to go but
it's an indispensable component of the
of the solution
anushka astana itv
thank you prime minister
prime minister the people you're talking
about
say they are fleeing persecution and
they often come from countries where
there are no safe routes here in the uk
why are you sending them with one-way
tickets to a country where there are
reports of ill-treatment and torture in
detention centres and that your own
government criticized last year for
failing to investigate these alleged
human rights violations and a quick
question because i'm not patient enough
to wait so i hope you will answer it but
on tuesday you've admitted that you
unknowingly misled parliament i just
want to understand if you're going to
put the record straight yeah uh thanks
so on on the
uh the the second point again the news
could forgive me uh you're gonna have to
wait until uh i uh i come to parliament
of course i will uh set the record
straight in any way that uh uh that i
can but on the um your point about safe
and legal routes i look i just i just
think it's crucial for people to
understand that the uk is
very very generous and
we should be proud as a country of what
we do to welcome people
185 000 just in the last few years and
it's not just the
people who came under op pitting from
afghanistan
we're opening our arms to to more uh
what we're doing uh with the ukrainian
scheme is
two uncapped uh systems of uh looking
after people coming from from ukraine
this is a country that is built on
successful uh immigration uh by safe and
legal roots but what we're trying to do
is to buttress that to to shore it up in
people's uh imaginations to make sure
that people believe in it and trust our
immigration system by cracking down on
the illegal approach and
and on the people smuggling
and i just want to say something about
rwanda because i think there's a risk of
of stereotyping here and uh
orlando has is totally transformed uh
over the last few decades it's it's a
very very different country uh from what
it was and
we are making sure
that we have a very very high degree of
confidence about the way uh people will
uh be received in rwanda we're today
publishing uh a
long uh memorandum of understanding
between the uk and rwanda about uh about
how they will be received and and
treated and this is not something that
we have uh put together overnight this
has been uh nine months in uh in
preparation so i would just urge people
you know not to to think in a blinkered
way about about rwanda
and
there will be
i i think this is the uh prototype of a
solution to the problems of global
migration flows that uh is likely to be
adopted by other countries i know that
there are other european countries that
are already in uh in similar discussions
not just with
rwanda but others billions of people are
going to be moving across the face of
the planet
we need sensible partnerships to address
those uh address those flows theo
washerwood of lbc
prime minister last year more than 28
000 migrants crossed the channel is your
aim to bring that number
down what will you do if this policy
fails to do that
and just on uh partygate you told the
comments on december the 8th that it
goes without saying that if the rules
were broken and there were then there
will be disciplinary action for all
those involved when you go to parliament
next week and you speak to mps and
you're in the house of commons will you
detail what that disciplinary action is
that you've imposed on those who work
for you and indeed yourself
uh thanks thanks theo i can certainly
tell you that i will be updating as i
said to uh to news current to nick i'll
be updating parliament all that uh next
week but on your on your your first
point um about
the numbers you look you're right you're
right the
um
the numbers are uh were high last year
but this year they're going to be even
higher there's no doubt about it i mean
they're already uh just in the first few
months of this of this year uh they're
higher than they were over over the
comparable uh period last year they're
growing uh this is the the uh people
smugglers are now becoming very adept
they're getting their their their boats
these frail frail things that you'll
have seen uh they're getting them uh in
huge numbers it looks as though they're
being you know manufactured to order in
in china uh they have a whole system
going now
and we need we need in a humane and
compassionate way to interrupt their
business model uh they're making i think
i think dan told me about 350 000
euros a boat something like that this is
this is a lucrative trade for them it is
a it is an evil trade and it's
undermining people's confidence in a
safe illegal migration uh we need to
emphasize the safe and legal routes and
uh and undermine the the the what the
people smugglers are doing and i just
want to you know be absolutely frank
with people theo this is not something
or this is i think the the deal that
we're doing with rwanda is an essential
uh part of the solution but it is not
the total uh solution it is it is a a uh
part of the the it is
one of several steps that we're taking
uh to beat the problem john stevens
daily mail
hi thank you prime minister um can i
just clarify is it your aim to bring the
numbers crossing the channel legally
eventually down to zero and on your
relationship with rishi sunak is he in
danger of being moved as chancellor or
can you say today that he's got that job
for as long as he wants it yeah sorry uh
so yes to the to the second and uh yes
to i think to the first obviously we do
want to uh make sure that
um
you know i'd like to get it down to zero
um i think everyone in this room i would
like to get it down to zero i think
people in this room do an absolutely
heroic job and it's incredibly difficult
uh to get the balance right and to be
firm but also to be humane and
compassionate to people very very
vulnerable people uh who are you know
who doing something that is extremely
brave and extremely dangerous and which
they shouldn't be which they shouldn't
be doing we what we want to show people
is that this is not only dangerous but
also likely to end in uh in in failure
for you that you're taking the wrong
step that there's a better solution and
you should you should wait and go uh via
the safe and legal route and not fall
victim to the people smugglers that's
what we're that's what we're trying to
do
aubry allegretti from the guardian
thank you prime minister um on top of
the concerns about the human rights
record of rwanda where people who will
be fleeing to the uk might obviously be
sent because they're facing persecution
at home there's also a cost element one
estimate puts it at two million pounds
per person per year and a conservative
mp andrew mitchell has suggested it
would be cheaper to put people up at the
ritz instead so are you comfortable with
the cost element of the plan and on the
party situation you faced why do we have
to wait another week
can you tell us whether or not you're
going to rule out resigning whether you
faced one two three or more fines thank
you okay so uh
aubry uh sec uh second question i
redirect you to what i said uh earlier
on i'm afraid that you went that won't
give you any uh particular surprise i
said quite a lot about this on uh
earlier in the week uh i i think i
should uh wait till uh until uh
parliament gets back to update
parliament fully and uh on your point
about about cost um look what's
happening already the the the
asylum system is already costing this
country 1.5 billion pounds a year
the hotel costs the hotel costs uh are
now 5 million pounds a day you talk
about the ritz they're now 5 million
pounds a day and it's climbing
and unless we can beat the business
model of the gangs i'm afraid it will
continue to climb and what we need to
put in place
is the deterrent system that will change
their minds make them see that they've
made the wrong deal and that there's a
better path uh for them if they really
want uh to come to the uk and that's
that's what we're doing today
last question to jonathan reilly of the
sun
prime minister
can you guarantee to the british people
that under your premiership there will
be no more small boats
and um secondly
the
home secretary is in kigali today would
she not be better off being in paris
speaking to the french officials there
and prioritizing a bilateral deal with
france to stop this um
and are you confident that post-french
elections uh that deal will be struck
thank you look i think that really
jonathan i think that's that is the the
you know the most important issue that
you've you've touched on and i think
it's the issue that's up in uppermost in
everybody's minds because who studied
this uh this problem uh and so you know
can i guarantee that we're gonna get rid
of the small bonus problem no obviously
not i think that the uh what we can hope
to do uh is to uh demolish the business
model and greatly to deter those who uh
who come here but uh to say that we're
gonna get down to to zero anytime soon
uh is is is unlikely and this will this
what we're proposing today
is i i think uh certainly a radical plan
but it will take a while to come fully
and properly into into effect but i just
want to say on um
[Music]
on france and on paris
pretty uh and many other ministers
have been continually uh in paris over
the last couple of years trying to
negotiate a returns agreement trying to
uh to sort this problem out and it is it
has been disappointing and frustrating
that we've been unable uh to do that uh
the french say it needs to be done at an
eu level uh that hasn't been uh
negotiable either
um
in my view in the view of many people
who studied this uh
there is more that could be done to
intercept people at the uh the french
side uh there is more that could be done
on the beaches uh in in france uh and uh
and now in belgium as well but
we're not here to to try to um
find fault with it with anybody else
today today is about the uk uh coming up
with its own solution in the absence of
a proper agreement with uh with france
and uh that's what we're doing and we'll
continue to work with i mean
a lot of the cooperation with the french
is excellent and we just think it could
go further and there's more to do i
think that'd be probably a fair summary
of it but in the meantime before we get
that uh what we need to do is have a uh
a more radical solution uh that enables
us uh for
as the uk to offer our own package and
to and to undermine the business case of
the uh of the people traffickers
and and that's what we're doing that's
the purpose of uh of this of this uh
whole package the military primacy the
new uh reception centers and the uh the
new uh
migration and economic partnership deal
with with rwanda that's what we're uh
we're trying to do uh i'm not going to
pretend it will work overnight but i do
believe that in time this is the best
way forward it is the morally right
thing to do it's the humane and the
compassionate thing to do as well
because we cannot have people continuing
to die sea uh paying huge sums uh to
evil uh people traffickers who are
simply exploiting their hopes and their
ambitions we need to encourage them to
take the safe and legal route if they
want to come to this country thank you
all very much thank you thank you
that was the prime minister uh speaking
live in kent
saying his new policy to stem illegal uh
immigration was the humane and
compassionate thing to do because he
says
they need to step
stop these vile people smugglers who are
exploiting the hopes and dreams of
people that want to come
to the uk
clearly the headline there is that from
now on people who arrive illegally
will be
swiftly and safely removed to a third
country or their country of origin the
prime minister just said that country is
rwanda he said the people that do
make it here in the meantime will be
housed in accommodation centers not
hotels and uh those that will be removed
to re rwanda won't be just from today
onwards but from those that have arrived
since the 1st of january uh illegally he
also
said that life sentences will be brought
in for the captain
of the ships that are doing the people
smuggling and that from now on
operational control uh of enforcing the
rules in english channel will be handed
over uh from the border force to the
royal navy quite a few significant
headlines on this new policy that has
been hastily announced today
coming out of that and the prime
minister perhaps because of the hasty
nature of the announcement
said that he does not expect it to come
into force immediately he does expect it
to be challenged in the courts uh he's
prepared to do whatever it takes in
order to
deliver it uh we've got reaction from uh
all corners now uh our political
correspondent rob powell uh sky's
madeline ratcliffe's who's in dover and
national haruna who's in sanget on the
site of a refugee camp
on the outside the french board of
calais let's get reaction from uh all
sides rob powell first of all in
westminster uh perhaps uh
to focus on the fact that uh the prime
minister's announcing this very
significant new policy but says it's not
going to come into play overnight he
expects it to be challenged in the
courts
yeah this is an extraordinary tricky
issue to try and find a solution to
and home office officials in various
parts of government have been working on
this um for months if not years now and
i think there was an acknowledgement of
that albeit a tacit one in what the
prime minister was saying there saying
that there is simply no other option
when he was talking about that decision
to send people that arrive via boats
illegally into the uk to rwanda
essentially an admission that all of the
other options that have been looked at
really haven't worked because
what we've seen pretty patel the home
secretary do in recent months has tried
to come to some sort of agreement with
france paying money to the french and
helping them with patrolling the coast
to try and stop people making
that journey that really hasn't worked
we've seen hundreds of people arriving
still
on just in just one day this week we've
seen them look at the government
potentially look at turning boats back
in the channel but you heard the prime
minister say in that that in that speech
that that was not practical in fact you
had border force officials saying
at the time that they would be hesitant
to do it
and i think what the prime minister is
trying to do is sort of frame this as
the humane compassionate
option that allows more people to come
through safe and legal routes i think
the danger is and i think it was
illustrated very visually from what
you're seeing on your screen right now
as the prime minister was laying out
this sort of new eye-catching plan to
send people to rwanda we were seeing
pictures of an official um in dover
carrying a child
onto land from a ship who had presumably
been rescued in the channel now um this
morning there was a suggestion that
actually it would only be single men
that would be part of this
new processing system to go out to
rwanda that was rode back on a little
bit by the home office um after that
saying that it was speculation so we
wait to to go through the detail i've
just seen an email drop into my inbox
with the detail uh now we're likely to
get more from the home secretary um in
rwanda as well in the coming
hour but really the rwanda aspect of
this is sort of just one piece of this
big asylum overhaul it's the most
eye-catching piece which is probably why
the government has sent the home
secretary out to rwanda to promote it
because frankly in the run-up to local
elections and under pressure on other
fronts it's in the government's interest
to prompt a fierce debate
about this issue because they believe
anyway that politically
many voters are on the side on their
side in terms of taking a tough approach
towards this but the other elements that
are coming as part of legislation which
still hasn't received royal assent i
think the amendments the changes that
the lords and the commons are making are
still being considered we'll make other
very big changes to the asylum system as
well requiring asylum seekers to put all
of their information down in what's
called a sort of one-stop shop um
applications which reduces their right
to appeal that will likely be challenged
um in the courts there is also uh new
changes in the law as well which mean
that uh the route in which you come into
the country influences how you're
treated obviously most obviously that if
you come in um on a small boat on a boat
then you could be sent to rwanda in
order to encourage what they say is safe
and legal route but that um lawyers have
said could be against the refugee
convention as well so that might be
challenged in the court um as well so
this is all incredibly incredibly tricky
um i think that it's in the government's
interest as i say to have this debate
and i think what we heard from the prime
minister there is the political point
that will be made from conservatives to
labor criticism of this which is quite
simply what is your alternative
rob uh thank you very much and as you
said i'm sure we'll be speaking to you a
little later again uh when we do hear
more from the home secretary as we heard
uh moments ago the prime minister's
warned that the number of people risking
their lives in the channel is set to
soar over the summer around 600 people
crossed the channel to arrive in the uk
just yesterday and the government says
the daily figure could rise to 1 000 in
just a few weeks more than 28 000 people
reached the uk in small boats in 2021
and at least 44 people including three
children died trying to cross the
channel to the uk let's go live now to
sky's madeleine ratcliffe in dover ashna
hyunag who's in sanget the site of a
refugee camp just outside the french
board of calais with us as well and uh
madeline to you first of all i mean we
just mentioned that of course
uh the numbers could soar uh over the
coming days i'm sure you're witnessing
some of those things over the last
couple of days down there in dover one
also wonders whether announcing a policy
before it's likely to take effect that's
aiming at deterring
migrants from making these journeys
would in fact spur them in the short
term
yes it's an interesting one isn't it
because while the prime minister was
talking we were watching
dozens and dozens of migrants who had
been brought in on a border force patrol
vessel being escorted off the boat and
and onto the land to be taken away for
protesting in a bus um and the idea
according to boris johnson is that
anyone who came in after uh january this
year will be sent to rwanda so these
people as well and he put a lot of focus
on the fact that these were young men
under 40 and certainly we have seen
plenty of them there have been two boats
that have come in so far this morning
one this border force vessel which had
quite a lot of people and a smaller boat
from the lifeguard which only had about
20 people but there have while there
have been a lot of young men there were
children on there as well we saw several
children being carried ashore wrapped up
in blankets they weren't walking
themselves and you know everyone there
had been given
their life jackets their blankets the
masks um and we think rescued from from
the sea so the idea that there's a lot
yet we don't know about how this will
work which of those people
how they decide who's eligible and who's
not because there seems to be some
uncertainty about who will be sent to
rwanda but the idea is that the people
who were coming ashore just as the prime
minister were speaking um this morning
could be taken to rwanda and it's um
certainly it has been quite a nice
morning today we have seen quite a lot
of people coming because the conditions
have have been good flats calm seas it's
been sunny but just in the last few
minutes very heavy cloud has come in
behind me completely reducing visibility
so you could set off from calais
thinking you've got the best day you
could giving yourself the best chance to
get across safely and by the time you
get to the dover cliffs it's not at all
the same it's very dangerous and
certainly it's incredibly dangerous no
matter what the weather when you're in
these tiny boats which really aren't
seaworthy they're dinghies often we saw
a border force uh vessel pulling behind
it some of the recovered dinghies that
had found and they just look like toys
they're so small and
inappropriate clearly for people making
this crossing especially when you see
them next to the proper boats in the
harbour
but despite that the weather does seem
to be encouraging more people we've now
with that 600 people who crossed
yesterday the prime minister confirmed
that takes us to more than 5000 this
year we didn't get to that stage until
june last year so it gives you a sense
of how many more people are crossing
about four times as many crosses in
march this year as they did last year so
people clearly are desperate and are
trying to to come across no matter the
risks
addie thank you um let's cross uh the
channel now and uh ashna who's in in
france ashley the prime minister
said during his comments there that he
accepts that these migrants are in
search of a better life but the vile
people smugglers are exploiting their
hopes and dreams and turning the channel
uh into a watery human uh graveyard i
imagine where you are based it's
witnessing some of the people who purely
have those hopes and dreams and are
searching for a better life
they really are and there are countless
uh people here waiting for indeed
searching for that better life they're
looking across and on a clear day behind
me i know it's quite misty but a clear
day you can see the white cliffs of
dover and you can start to imagine and
build a new future in your life for many
people who have fled persecution as many
of the journalists put to the prime
minister and fled war zones including a
number that we've spoken to today um at
a camp just down the road in dunkirk we
spoke to a group of afghani
men aged between about 17 to 18 some in
their 20s and they'd fled they said two
war zones not only had they come from
afghanistan in august when the taliban
regained power they fled that country
and crossed the borders of iran and
crossed into turkey they then made their
way into ukraine
and then as we know
that two weeks
ago some nearly a month ago now once
again they found themselves in a war
zone they managed to gain visas in
ukraine hence why they were they were
there and they were working there and
they fled
that war zone and made their way here to
northern france where they are
desperately trying again and again to
board one of those inflatable
dinghies but we spoke to one of them who
didn't have any idea of this news of
course
news isn't the priority i suppose when
you're looking forward to getting on a
boat and trying desperately to to risk
your life in that way but when we told
them of this announcement they were
exasperated they said this felt brutally
unfair they'd been looking at the way at
which other refugees had been treated
they referenced the fact that refugees
fleeing ukraine had been
held held in in high regard they've been
new schemes set up purely for them they
felt frustrated and they felt as though
they were being ignored and they were so
incredibly desperate for help and they
said why wouldn't they have fled through
countries in the middle east and then
tried to make their way to here and then
to the uk why would they then be sent to
east africa they couldn't understand it
and these aren't just young men of
course but we are talking about
women and children too but we did just
happen to speak to this group of young
men who said that yes they tried to
board a vote yesterday they will try
again tonight and truthfully they will
keep trying but there's something else
that the prime minister uh picked upon
there he spoke of the talks that have
been happening with france and we know
that over a number of years this isn't a
new issue is it the home secretary
pretty patel's been going over meeting
her french counterpart here
in uh paris and in other cities in
northern france and there's been for
herself to see the way that these
businesses are operating and they are
very much businesses people smugglers
profiting hugely from this and there was
some criticism from the prime minister
there saying that talks had been
disappointing saying that things needed
to move much further and this he saw uh
is as it is a last resort but when we
spoke to the french interior minister
last year they very much said that they
are at capacity they are trying their
best
24 hours off not often 24 hours but
around the clock there is surveillance
here their hardware has improved they've
got binoculars binoculars they've got a
reinforced aerial surveillance just a
moment ago the police came down to check
this particular beach and up above we've
heard the coast guard helicopter too so
both sides are saying that they are
doing as much as they can crucially
though what this scheme is all about is
about clamping down on the people who
are profiting it from it
profiting from it as i mentioned those
people smugglers people have paid
thousands of thousands of pounds for a
place on one of those dinghies wearing
those life jackets and at dawn you will
see them on beaches like this trying
their luck trying to get to the other
side
and this new measure this idea of moving
people um for processing and processing
their settlement um
applications moving them to rwanda
putting that to people here the asylum
seekers here that's really not going to
deter them
thank you very much uh for that uh john
vine who was the uk's first independent
chief inspector of borders and
immigration uh joins me now to discuss
this
further john many many questions my
first is the one that i guess takes
operational effect immediately um
which is that the royal navy is now in
charge
of operations in
the channel rather than the border force
what is your take on that
well i think that was flagged up um some
time ago that that was going to happen i
mean this whole new idea this new model
is based on what happened in australia
between 2012 and 2015.
that was operation sovereign borders
called
and the military took charge
of
the straits between papua new guinea and
the north of the northern coast of
australia and they turned back
boats and they also
interred people into parts of papua new
guinea and also a small country called
nauru
and so this is a model which has been
tried before and to be fair
it did it didn't succeed in its aim of
actually stopping um
boats coming and depositing migrants on
the shores of northern australia but it
was tremendously controversial from a
human rights
and refugee and asylum point of view
and listening to the prime minister's
speech today
he flagged up several times that it
would be hard it would be hard going and
there'll be a lot of challenges to this
and i think it's going to need a great
deal of political resolve
so with that with that in mind does it
surprise you that the announcement has
come before sorting out some of those
issues or or is that to be expected
no i think i think what they
needed to do was to come up with a plan
to avoid what happened last year which
was very reactive
uh bearing in mind that three times as
many migrants reached our chores in this
irregular way
last year compared with the year before
and i think what the home office and the
government can see is this is only going
to get worse this year much much worse
and so this is basically a preemptive
strike to
try and deter
uh people from handling over large sums
of money to people smugglers and risking
their lives and coming to britain in
this way and um
it remains to be seen whether that's
going to work in this context
it's um
it's going to be subject to a lot of
challenge though uh on human rights
grounds and people will be looking at
the way
uh it's implemented
you know how do you get lots of people
onto planes and fly them 4 000 miles
away to central africa
you know what's that going to look like
what's the optics going to be around
that
and what happened in australia sometimes
is that you know there were there was um
disorder and there was
people self-harming in the camps in
papua new guinea
and so there were lots of issues around
the rights of individuals and the way
that they were treated
in camps so
people will be looking to see how this
is going to be operated
and the detail of course which we don't
really have yet will be poured over i'm
sure
um
john we heard the prime minister asked a
couple of times there whether he would
be better served trying once again to
strike better deals
more effective deals with uh with the
french and uh the eu more broadly
um
is that advisable and and who bears
responsibility ultimately for that big
increase that you mentioned
in number of small boat crossings from
france
just last year which of course does uh
did arrive the first year of brexit
well the bottom line is that the
there has been cooperation on the ground
with the french authorities i'm sure the
police forces and border force officials
are working effectively together on the
ground but you have to realize that
we're talking about hundreds of miles of
french coastline
and it's virtually impossible to have
law enforcement presence on all the
occasions when organized crime are sort
of floating people in inadequate vessels
and pushing them out towards
the coast of the uk
and so there's only so much you can do
in terms of enforcement what the home
office is trying to do now is attack the
business model
um you know people are handing over
large sums of money to organize crime um
with a sort of a guarantee that they're
going to get to the uk
and
the government's saying well you're not
going to get to uk and the
uh the prime minister used the word
deterrence quite a lot in this
presentation this is about
saying look it's not worth it don't
bother trying
uh so
we'll have to see whether in fact that
works
and and
john putting just momentarily to one
side the moral question uh here that
you've already raised the human rights
question which is
obviously incredibly important but if we
were just to put that to one side in
your position as an expert on
borders and immigration do you think
this policy will work and and get these
crossings down significantly
well it did it did work in australia in
terms of reducing the number of boats
that came to australia um illegally um
so
in terms of that short-term aim it will
probably have an impact but it depends
on
rigorous enforcement
but it also um it'll also be challenged
legally and the legislation
which is the nationality borders bill is
still making its passage through
parliament it's not yet received royal
assent
and um you know there are a lot of
powers that the government's proposing
in that legislation that haven't yet
been agreed by parliament
and so there will be pushbacks in terms
of in legal terms and people will be
looking to the the way you know these uh
migrants and silencers are treated
so um there's a lot of devil in the
detail
which we know little about at the moment
john thanks so much for joining me john
vine uh the uk's uh first uh independent
chief inspector of borders and
immigration
we're gonna stay on this story uh of
course uh now and our political
correspondent rob powell and westminster
able to to join me once again and rob
you have some fresh updates on this uh
this developing story
yeah we've been starting to get um some
of the details through about how
practically this policy um and this
partnership deal that's been signed with
rwanda
will work now the home office says that
it will apply to anyone who i'm quoting
now makes dangerous illegal or
unnecessary journeys so that would
include people that arrive
in boats and dinghies as we've been
seeing this morning it would also
include people that arrive
in lorries coming through the channel
tunnel for example as well
crucially and in contrast to some of the
briefing or on the record comments
really from cabinet ministers this
morning there is no indication that this
will just apply to single men it says
that this
may apply anyway to everyone so i think
we read into that that potentially um
men women children families could be
sent to rwanda to have their asylum
claims processed if they are deemed to
have arrived in the uk um through a
dangerous illegal or unnecessary route
so what will happen essentially is that
this will apply to people backdated to
january so some of the people that we've
seen arriving on the kent coast today
may well be notified um even
in the coming weeks that they are being
taken to rwanda the first flights are
expected to take off to take people to
rwanda in the coming months
as well so we've got a degree of time
scale in terms of practically what will
happen when people um are picked up now
by of course the navy which is taking
primacy um
on um
managing this um in the channel is that
they will be processed on the kent coast
and then taken to a separate
centre a bit further inland at manston
in kent
and from there we don't necessarily have
a sort of time scale between arrival and
being taken to rwanda but from there
there will be decisions made and then
they may be notified that they are to be
taken to rwanda now once they arrive at
the processing center in rwanda that is
where the asylum claim um will be
considered if the asylum claim is deemed
as successful and legitimate
then they will get
refugee status in rwanda and so they
will get
a five-year package of training and
support to
as the government puts it form a new
life
in rwanda if their claim is unsuccessful
uh then they will either um be um taken
back to their country of origin or they
may be taken to another eligible country
or crucially as well they may be given a
different type of immigration status
in rwanda
as well so
that's the one part of it the second
part of this is the government setting
out what it wants to do to
as they say anyway
curb the extortionate cost
of asylum seekers that are currently
being housed in hotels across the
country part of this will uh mean the
building the transformation of
an old raf base um in linton on ooze
into a refugee holding center so some of
the ref some of the people that have
come before january that are still in um
hotels when they wait for their claim to
be considered um will be taken here so
the emphasis i think very much being put
on deterrence the hope of the rwanda
part of this policy i think will be
ultimately that they don't need to use
it too much because if there is that um
sort of threat that you won't be able to
stay in the uk then fewer people will
try to make the journey
and ultimately people smugglers won't be
able to take them across or charge
people the extortion at some to take
them
across the channel
i guess the proof of this is going to be
firstly in how many people
are actually transferred to rwanda and
how successful that is
in terms of resettling people there
um how expensive it is we were just
hearing from the previous guests that
the policy in australia
worked in terms of discouraging people
from making the journey but it was also
absolutely extortionately expensive
so there's the practical policy aspects
of that and then there are the of course
the ethical aspects of it as well
um
in terms in what happened in australia
we have heard um of suicides of murders
of other instances of abuse that have
gone on in some of these resettlement
camps um as well
this all comes though i think as one
part of a wider overhaul that the
government is trying to do on the asylum
system
and i think as i say the political
argument that they will be making around
this and i don't think they mind having
this argument today as fierce as it may
be
is that they have a plan they have
something they think will work
and people that are criticizing it
should put forward an alternative but i
think one very very legitimate crucial
point to make is that the government is
putting emphasis on safe and legal
routes into the uk well when you talk to
refugee charities and lawyers they say
that there simply isn't aren't enough of
those safe and legal routes so it's all
very well saying you can't come in boats
or on the back of lorries anymore and
that won't work you've got to do the
safe and legal routes but but that's not
really um a sort of humane point to make
if you like if the safe and legal routes
simply aren't there and simply can't be
practically accessed by people fleeing
war who may be or are in fact in one of
the most vulnerable points of their life
powell in westminster for us thank you
very much now the uh government's plans
to fly
asylum seekers to veranda for processing
is an attempt to tackle the rising
number of small boat crossings uh in the
channel offshoring the process will
change the system in the uk but will
potentially also affect the situation on
the french coast
where the boats tend to leave from i'm
joined now by french mep and member
of the committee on civil liberties
justice and home affairs fabian keller
very good to see you
madam keller thanks for for joining me
this morning what is the french reaction
to this new policy just announced by
prime minister boris johnson
actually it's a shock
uh uk is applying the geneva convention
and this means that
all asylum seekers all migrants asking
for protection
needs to have a proposal made to them
to check their file if they can remain
or not and if they cannot
ever swift a correct human return to
their country of origin and as you know
we have many people
on the french coast
expecting to rejoin
uk not willing at all to apply for a
zero in
the rest of europe
but
in in uk itself
and the idea of sending them with the
army
on boats of the army to rwanda
is really a terrible proposal
the prime minister
did mention there that a very high
percentage we don't know exactly
of those seeking asylum in the uk via
this route across english channel have
come
from safe countries uh from uh countries
like france
uh and that they could alternatively
seek asylum there that they're not being
persecuted uh from their final port of
disembarkation if you like what is your
view on that
two points the first
when uk was part of europe the
dublin rule was
in application that means that it was
possible to ask the member state the
european member state where the migrant
entered to take him
charge
it's called take charge
and to examine is as even demand
as
great britain left
the european union this rule is not
anymore applicable that's a factual
point
second point
uh most
a lot of people
who are staying in the on the french
coast
have family in
in the uk have relationships they know
why they don't apply in europe but want
to join the uk
and
it's not it's not respecting
international convention it's not a
human way to do it by sending them in
another country which is not at all
their own country
where they maybe
lived before
it's it's a false
answer to a real problem we share in all
european countries but it's
more
in discussions with the french but also
the belgian as proposed by the european
union then that we can find a human
solution for this question and respect
the geneva convention that's very
important we have to protect
all the people in the world
who are asking for protection
i must say that it's it's a a very
strange situation at a time where europe
is welcoming four million refugees from
ukraine and as you may know uh great
britain is taking a very small share of
this only
thousands of people could uh
join uk to be protected
i i totally understand your your point
on on that and the numbers um just to go
back to the the dublin rule you
mentioned
um that that rule may legally no longer
um apply but but morally does that also
mean that france has no responsibility
to those people seeking asylum because
they ultimately excuse excuse me
actually madame calip maybe you can
stick around and we can discuss things a
little bit further but we're gonna
travel now to rwanda and listen to the
home secretary
let me start by welcoming the home
secretary her team and members of the uk
press to rwanda
for the launch of this new partnership
together
rwanda and the united kingdom have
developed a truly unique approach to
address
the global migration crisis
this migration and economic development
partnership reflects rwanda's commitment
to protecting vulnerable people
a principle which always governs the
international policy
of our government
it will also address a serious equity
issue
which is the global imbalance in
opportunities for human capacity
development
which is driving irregular
migration
because of rwanda's recent history
we have a deep connection to the plight
of those seeking safety
and opportunity in a new land
as you may be aware wanda was formerly
one of the world's
leading producers of refugees and many
rwandans
have experienced what it means to be
displaced
this has shaped how we approach
migration and asylum
rwanda already provides a refuge for
almost 130 000 refugees from
multiple countries
including neighbors like the drc and
burundi
as well as afghanistan and migrants
evacuated from libya
this work has involved partnering with
international bodies such as the nhcr
the international organization for
migration
and the african union
and we remain open to continue working
with these and other organizations
on these new program
for there to be meaningful long-term
solutions to the migration crisis
which is causing huge suffering to
millions
we need to do more than just give
shelter
it is possible to frame migration in
another way
and it is an opportunity for all
societies to thrive
fear and suspicion of those who need to
move to build a better life
makes it harder for all of us to better
work
out
win-win solutions for all
migrants make social
cultural and economic contributions to
societies in which they integrate
we believe that africans and others from
elsewhere should be able to live safe
dignified lives in africa and should not
be locked out of opportunity
this is why we need to work with
partners on bold new approaches which
tackle the root causes of irregular
migration
while providing immediate safety and
opportunity to those currently in need
madame home secretary
this is why rwanda is pleased to work
with the uk on this partnership
by relocating by relocating migrants to
rwanda
investing in their personal development
and providing education employment and
other opportunities
we are giving them the chance to make
new lives in our country as full members
of our communities
these will not only help them but it
will benefit rwanda and rwandans and
help to advance our own development
and for those who don't wish to make
rwanda their new home they will be
facilitated to return to their country
of origin or settle in other receiving
countries
we believe this partnership with the uk
offers a unique
and innovative approach that will
provide the safe haven
and opportunity to those in need
and be the first crucial step towards a
more effective and human global
migration system
we look forward to partnering with the
uk
on this exciting program
i thank you all and welcome the home
secretary to make her remarks
before we take a few questions from the
media madame home secretary the floor is
yours thank you so much and um thank you
for your incredibly warm welcome
certainly to my delegation and our
colleagues from the uk media as well
i'm delighted to be here in kigali
alongside our friend and partner
minister dr vincent bruto and i just
would like to express my personal thanks
in particular to him and his team for
the constructive way in which we have
been working
over many many months to achieve and
deliver this partnership
the united kingdom has a long and proud
development history with rwanda and our
shared interests have resulted in a
strong and strong economic and
development growth lifting millions out
of poverty but also resulting in growing
manufacturing and technology sectors
which are generating jobs and
sustainable
growth for generations to come
now i know firsthand that your country
minister is a regional and international
leader you are on the global stage very
much yourself more often than not but
also hosting the commonwealth heads of
government meeting the world
telecommunications development
conference and the sustainable energy
for all forum your national leadership
is the african voice on international
initiatives which really speaks to
seeking to find solutions to regional
and international challenges
and i'm very honored to be here and the
uk is delighted to be working ever more
closely with rwanda
we have many many interests in common
and we face many of the same challenges
and i want to turn to one of those
challenges now
the global migration crisis and how we
tackle illegal migration requires new
world leading solutions there are an
estimated 80 million people displaced in
the world and the global approach to
asylum and migration is broken
evil people smugglers and their criminal
gangs are facilitating people into
europe resulting in the loss of life and
shoe costs to the uk taxpayer
the tragic loss of life of people in the
channel and in the mediterranean at the
hands of these evil people smugglers
must stop
and today
our approach as to outward-looking
countries has led to the signing of a
new international partnership which is a
world first it is a migration and
economic development partnership with
the country of rwanda and the uk
this will see some of those arriving
illegally in the uk such as those
crossing the channel in dangerous small
boats relocated to rwanda to resettle
and to rebuild their lives in the way in
which the ministers just outline
more than 28 000 migrants crossed the
channel last year by small boat in very
dangerous and perilous conditions
the uk asylum system is collapsing under
a combination of real humanitarian
crises and evil people smugglers
profiteering by exploiting the system
for their own gains
criminals are exploiting the hopes and
fears of migrants pushing them to making
dangerous journeys to the uk with
fictitious and false promises that they
can settle in the uk if they make it
and this has devastating consequences
for the countless men women and children
who have tragically lost their lives or
loved ones on perilous journeys
it is also deeply unfair because it
advantages those with the means to pay
smugglers over the vulnerable who cannot
global systems and conventions have
failed to address this global crisis
and the world has changed and renewed
global leadership is required to find
new innovative solutions to this growing
problem
today the united kingdom and rwanda have
signed a joint new migration and
economic development partnership to put
an end to this deadly trade in people
smuggling
this is part of the united kingdom's new
plan for immigration to control our
borders protect our communities stop
dangerous illegal migration help the
world's most desperate people and
welcome international talents to the uk
it is the biggest overhaul of our
immigration system in decades
underpinned by a nationality and borders
bill which will soon become law
our country the united kingdom has
always extended the hand of friendship
to those in need in recent years alone
we have proudly welcomed tens of
thousands of refugees from syria
afghanistan ukraine and bno's from hong
kong
rwanda has one of the strongest records
for refugee resettlement and in recent
years as the minister has just
said miranda has resettled over 130 000
refugees
it has an established record of
welcoming and integrating people such as
those from the democratic republic of
congo and burundi
but also
including for example people from libya
evacuate evacuated under the eu's
emergency transit mechanism in
partnership with the um refugee agency
and the african union rwanda is also a
state party to the 1951 u.n refugee
convention and the seven core principles
of the un human rights convention
border control is fundamental to
national sovereignty
uncontrolled immigration reduces our
capability and capacity to help those
who need our support it puts intolerable
pressures on public services and on
local communities and at home as the
prime minister has said today because
the capacity of the asylum system is not
unlimited the presence of economic
migrants which these illegal routes
introduce into the asylum system
inhibits our ability to support others
in genuine need of protection
the british people are fair and generous
when it comes to helping those in need
but the persistent circumventing of our
laws and immigration rules and the
reality of a system that is open to
gaming and criminal exploitation has
eroded public support for britain's
asylum system and those that genuinely
need access to it
putting evil people smugglers out of
business is a moral imperative
it requires us to use every tool at our
disposal and also to find new solutions
that is why today's migration and
economic development partnership with
rwanda is a major milestone
it is also very much in keeping with our
vision for global britain that harnesses
the potential for new relationships and
stimulates investments and jobs in
partner countries
working together
the united kingdom and rwanda will help
make the immigration system fairer
ensure that people are safe and enjoy
new opportunities to flourish
we have agreed that people who enter the
uk illegally will be considered for
relocation to rwanda to have their
asylum systems their asylum claims
decided
and those who are resettled will be
given the support including up to five
years of training with the help of
integration accommodation healthcare so
that they can resettle and thrive
this agreement fully complies with all
international and national law
and as part of this groundbreaking
agreement the uk is making a substantial
investment in the economic development
of rwanda
this will support programs to improve
the lives of people in rwanda and
develop the country the economy job
prospects and opportunities in addition
the uk will provide funding and
expertise to implement this agreement
as i have said many many times
this is a global issue
with many countries struggling to
address the challenges and the causes
and there is no single or simple
solution
this agreement illustrates that we can
no longer accept the status quo
people are dying and the global
migration crisis requires new ways
to find new partnerships and to find new
solutions
it will also deal a major blow to the
evil people smugglers
we know that this will not be easy we
know that we will face challenges along
the way but together with the
nationality and borders bill and the new
plan for immigration the uk will support
those fleeing oppression and persecution
in tyranny through safe and legal routes
while controlling our borders and
deterring illegal entry
our world leading migration and economic
development partnership is a global
first and it'll change the way we
collectively tackle illegal migration
through new innovative and world-leading
solutions thank you
[Applause]
thank you so much my name is james
and i work with the new times in rwanda
minister
minister veruta
my question is
how has rwanda has experienced previous
experience
in
welcoming in hosting integrating
refugees and asylum seekers
informed this
decision on the part of the government
of rwanda and madame secretary my
question is
how
how did you
reach arrive at the decision to pick
runner to be a partner in this process
what factors do you look at thank you
thank you
yes i think i mentioned something about
this in my
remarks when i said that rwanda is
already hosting more than 130 000
refugees from countries like burundi
like drc or even
afghanistan
and i also said that
our people here in rwanda
a good
number of them have
in their previous lives
faced these challenges of being
displaced being refugees or asylum
seekers so all these are the these
experiences informed
the government of rwanda
to be convinced that we should do
something about
this problem of irregular migration
there will be one way to
look at this problem one would be to
just look at it and be
just
indifferent
the other one will be to try new
solutions because the problem is there
you have good principles in place but
they are not working
so as a government we thought that we
need eventually to partner with
the uk among others
to do something about
the existing problem so our history our
past has informed
our decision to work with the uk on
innovative solutions to
the migration crisis
thank you
thank you minister um james thank you
for your question and you've asked how
did
we reach the conclusion to partner with
rwandan and as the minister has said um
this is very much number one a
partnership um and clearly we
engage in dialogue and we have been for
over nine months now but rwanda has a
very unique history in terms of refugees
and resettlement resettlement in
particular
first and foremost rwanda is a safe and
secure country with the respect for the
rule of law and clearly a range of
institutions that have evolved and
developed over time and with that the
skilled way in which rwanda has already
provided resettlement for almost 130 000
refugees from multiple countries
and look at that alongside many of the
um good innovations that have taken
place along with some of the investments
um the economic development the
fundamental principle of respecting
human capital and investing in people um
if i may say so rwanda has been very
forward-leaning and has been very
dynamic in the conversations that we've
had as well around yes economic growth
and the partnership but respect for
people
and giving them the ability to find new
opportunities but effectively restart
their lives rebuild careers potentially
and settle here successfully
cheeky murray from sky news australia
have set up their own offshore
processing system and there are reports
of uh self-harming and even people
taking their own lives because these
people
are going through
tremendously difficult times with their
mental health and they've made a
difficult journey i wanted to just ask
how will you ensure the well-being of
asylum seekers sent to rwanda do you see
that as a uk government's responsibility
or are you passing the buck to the
rwandan government on this i also wanted
to ask a question of the rwandan
minister beruta
there's a massive backlog of cases to
get through when it comes to uk asylum
claims you could be welcome welcoming
thousands of people here how are you
going to ensure you have the
infrastructure to make sure that works
thank you very much
so first of all let me um just say um
this is a partnership this is a
partnership between our two countries
first and foremost this isn't a
one-sided deal so i just want to
absolutely deconstruct any myths around
that we have been working together in
fact i actually just want to pay tribute
to our teams because it's our officials
that for nine months um over nine months
in fact that have been working um on a
lot of detail and when we publish our
mou the memorandum of understanding you
will see the detail how much work has
taken place in terms of um being fair
and having the right processes to
respect people that come here to rwanda
to resettle australia is not comparable
this is not the type of arrangement that
australia had australia as a sovereign
country obviously had its own
arrangement
it is fair to say
our teams have been working through
facilities here you've heard me mention
in my opening remarks as well the
technical experience that we are
bringing we believe in investing in
rwanda we're very open about that
we believe that's the right thing to do
yes on the economic development side but
also on the migration partnership we as
two ministers stand here today
absolutely committed to changing some of
the norms around the broken global
migration system because for too long
other countries and by the way naysayers
just sit on their hands and have been
watching people die so we have the right
processes in place we have the right
mechanisms for scrutiny the checks and
balances that is incredibly important
and you heard me say in my remarks as
well about respect of rule of law but
importantly as well national and
international laws and conventions
so in addition to the infrastructure
aspect of the program
when we were discussing
this partnership we assessed our
capacity to
receive migrants and we know that we
have a capacity in place to
to receive migrants but we'll be also
investing in new infrastructures
going forward
and we are looking at shelters but we
are also looking at investing in social
infrastructures for this program to take
place we are looking at investing in
education we are looking at investing in
housing for the migrants but also for
our own people so we have been working
on all
aspects of the program including
the infrastructure program we are ready
and we going forward we are going to
keep investing with the support of the
uk to have the capacity to we need to
receive the migrants
um
we are listening to the rwandan foreign
minister and alongside the british home
secretary pretty patel uh vincent beruta
is currently speaking in rwanda we'll
dip back in when the questions and
answers come back to english just to sum
up some of the headlines that have come
out of this press conference uh so far
is that uh pretty patel the home
secretary uh saying that she thinks the
nationality and borders bill will become
law soon of course that is required in
order to put in action uh this new plan
from uh the government uh
said there that uh the plan is to
resettle
uh
illegal migrants into the uk to rwanda
and start a new life there the
implication i took from that was it
would be permanent resettlement uh not a
temporary uh period in miranda saying
that the uk is making investments in
rwanda that this is a partnership it
involves economic
development not just to solve the
migrant crisis
and also in an answer to a question to
sky's
about whether or not the responsibility
for observing of human rights
of these people that will be resettled
to random who that would lay with
we didn't get a clear answer on that
talked about this being a very much a
partnership not a one-sided deal
saying that the australian situation who
have enacted something like this in the
past was not comparable that they're
keen to have the right processes in
place with checks and balances
and mentioned uh in her answer
uh national and international law but
did not uh outright uh answer the
question uh from uh shingi as to whether
or not the responsibility uh for those
migrants once a miranda would be uh on
the uk or on rwanda
saying that this is not a single simple
solution to the migrant crisis that many
countries uh face and uh the uk
is doing something new something fresh
and uh
wants to put the evil people smugglers
out of business calling that uh a moral
imperative of course we did hear from
prime minister boris johnson uh earlier
in the day as he outlined this process
also mentioned uh that uh the
responsibility uh operational command in
the english channel immediately would
shift from the border force to the royal
navy whereas the rest of these
announcements will require the
nationality and borders bill to pass
and boris johnson saying that he didn't
think that would happen
overnight he said that it would be a
challenge in the courts he expected that
he knows the system
will not take effect immediately but
he's prepared to do whatever it takes
take the necessary legal reforms in
order uh to deliver it uh there is uh on
the screen vincent beruta the randons
foreign minister uh still been talking
uh in rwanda let's just have a little
listen and see if we get a question and
an answer now in english chloe chaplin
from the iron newspaper home secretary
the home office has said that the first
people in the uk will be notified of
their relocation within a matter of
weeks and flown in a matter of months
but we understand that the random
government is still in negotiations over
the lease of the first accommodation so
what is a realistic timeline for when
the first people will arrive and how
many people are you expecting to be
relocated by the end of the year and
foreign minister will you be accepting
claims from people who present directly
to rwanda and not by the uk thank you
chloe thank you
first of all i'm not going to get into
details of numbers you've heard me say
i think probably over the last two years
as home secretary that removing people
um from the uk with no legal basis um to
be in the uk is difficult and it is hard
and i have to say i'm sure that there
are many of you in this room that have
written about some of the legal cases
and things of that nature and some of
the barriers that we face but don't
forget as well that's why we have the
new plan for immigration the national
anthem borders bill we are ready to
operationalize and that's incredibly
important i do want to emphasize that
that is the nature of our partnership so
our teams have been coming here for
months and months and months not just to
negotiate but to look at how we can
operationalize this partnership and of
course that covers resettlement
accommodation the practicalities meeting
people's care needs legal needs etc etc
we have a plan a joint plan together to
do that and you've asked about the
accommodation facilities here and leases
i mean obviously that is for the
government here
but we know through the work that our
technical teams have been doing
week after week and even over the days
that we've been here as well and i had a
team prior to my arrival here as well
we've all been working through the
specific details of removals and also
where the first arrivals will go to
on the second question this program will
be
dedicated to
asylum seekers who are already in the uk
for other people who want to come to
wander to to seek asylum
or who want to be refugees in this
country there are existing channels and
those one will be used and the
government of one wonder we use
the existing programs to
to address that that aspect so
direct flights for people want to come
here and benefit from this program
it won't work they
it is addressing people who are seeking
asylum
from the uk and who are already in the
uk for others there are existing
mechanisms which will be
used and they have been
used in the past the
using
they are still being used today
thank you
just right here
my question is for you both uh
i want you to know what's going to be
the creatures you're going to use to
select the immigrant people they're
going to reach in rwanda
and of course how many times they're
going to stay in rwanda
thank you minister thank you so you've
asked about eligibility and selection
for people to come to rwanda um we're
very clear that everyone who enters the
uk illegally
will be considered
for
resettlement and being brought over to
rwanda i'm not going to divulge specific
criterias for a number of reasons
because quite frankly we are trying to
break the model of the people smuggling
gangs who use a range of
ways in which to provide facilitation to
our country and then obviously provide
legal challenges to us as well but the
vast majority i think it's important to
say this of people that have been
arriving to the uk via illegal means
such as small boats by the people
smugglers
you know will obviously
be considered to be relocated
maybe i can add that some of the
criteria will be considering as
government of wonder would be
let's say criminal record for example
and
would prefer not to receive people from
neighboring countries immediate
neighbors
like drc like burundi uganda or tanzania
but those are just some but there will
be a system in place to screen for those
who
would wish to come here
or those who
have been identified as people
likely to benefit from this program so
we have a team in place and
we need to go through
the files and
set a number of criteria
and we keep working with the uk
government on this thinking
home secretary some of these asylum
seekers will have family in the united
kingdom and will end up thousands of
miles away at a country which was not of
their choosing why do you think that
those asylum cities are better off in
rwanda than in the united kingdom and
the second question if i may if a
ukrainian refugee were to arrive via an
unofficial route if they were to get on
a boat across the channel would they be
eligible to be sent to rwanda and
another question to you minister beruta
britain is essentially saying that these
asylum seekers are not welcome but you
are willing to take them why are these
asylum seekers welcome in rwanda and not
in the uk what is the difference
so shah thank you for your question and
first of all let me just differentiate
um between those who are admissible and
inadmissible to the asylum system i
think it's fair to say we've spoken
about this many times you've heard me
repeatedly
speak about differentiation in terms of
who will have access to our asylum
system and who will will not those that
will have access to the asylum system
under the new plan for immigration all
our work in government you heard the
prime minister say this this morning
will be those coming through safe and
legal routes and obviously those fling
persecution oppression and tyranny we've
said that from day one in fact when i
published the new plan for immigration
last year i was incredibly explicit
about that we are speaking specifically
about those who are coming to our
country through illegal means small
boats for example and refrigerated
lorries in the hands of people smugglers
we need to absolutely stop that from
happening and we have to stop this
criminal trade so differentiation is
absolutely vital and that is what we are
speaking about through this partnership
migration and economic development
partnership it will be those individuals
who are not admissible to the uk asylum
system and you've heard me speak
frequently about parallel routes that
are basically making our asylum system
completely dysfunctional the system is
broken it has no differentiation and the
people p those who pay the evil people
smugglers get into the front of the
queue while we have people that are
being left behind women children
families that actually need our help and
support your second question you asked
about ukraine now let me be clear we
have a safe and legal route for
ukrainian nationals seeking to come to
the united kingdom there is no reason
why anybody should come to the country
via the people smugglers and that is
effectively the model that we want to
break we want to stop this this vile
trade this inhumane trade where criminal
gangs and smugglers are just
profiteering and making so much money
and doing all sorts of inhumane things
to people that are coming over in
lorries and also in boats
you'll also know that with the ukrainian
scheme over 50 000 visas have been
granted it is a safe and legal route
there are ways in which people can
safely come to the united kingdom and
that's an uncapped roof let me remind
you it's an uncapped route that's quite
unprecedented it's the first unk capped
route of this kind set up by the british
government
okay the people who are talking here
are illegal migrants it's not about
people choosing to stay here or to be
maybe
better off in one place or another it is
about illegal migrants those are
stateless people who don't have any
status in the uk or
and we need to we just decided to give
our contribution to a solution to
a illegal migration
and we are going to provide these people
with
a minimum
for them to be able to
live a dignified life we are going to
invest in
skill development we're going to invest
in social economic integration of these
people so
one of what someone would choose maybe
to to stay in the uk as he chose to
cross the
europe to to reach the uk
but
what we are going to provide with them
is that
a dignified life with
shelter with skills for them to be able
to social economically integrate our
society or to have those skills for them
to be able to integrate in the the
country of origin when they say they
decide to go
back to their countries or to relocate
to another place which will be
available to receive them so that's what
we're going to do it is not about just
anyone choosing to stay in determined
countries we are dealing with a legal
migration that way we need to focus and
to be able to make it to
to give our contribution to the problem
thank you
thanks very much everyone thank you
the press conference they're just
wrapping up between the home secretary
pretty patel and the foreign minister of
rwanda vincent beruta we heard some of
the key headlines there coming out of it
including the fact that
this is a partnership in the
words of the home secretary priti patel
and that those that are resettled to
rwanda will be given up to five years uh
to uh
so that they can thrive with investment
uh and funding and expertise coming from
the uk side um and also that the home
secretary felt that the nationality and
borders bill will become law soon that
is required uh for some of this to come
into action uh prime minister boris
johnson saying earlier that he didn't
think it would happen overnight he did
expect things to be challenged in the
court but he would do whatever it takes
in order to deliver it lots to unpack uh
from both that press conference and
boris johnson's earlier we're joined by
our political correspondent rob powell
who's in westminster
and sky's madeline ratcliffe who's in
dover uh and rob i come to you first of
all uh in terms of
i think the key thing to come out of
that press conference was uh in response
to a question for our from our own